.
PETER DOOCY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE NEED IT.
KEVIN MCCARTHY, REPUBLICAN FROM
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOW ANOTHER BIDEN
EMERGENCY.
JUST FIRST OF ALL, HOW DIRE
STRAITS ARE WE IN AS A NATION
WITH BIDEN POLICIES ON ENERGY
NOW?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY PLACES
WE'RE IN DIRE STRAITS ALL
CREATED BY ONE-PARTY RULE BY THE
DEMOCRATS CONTROLLING THE HOUSE,
SENATE AND PRESIDENCY.
HE ENDED AN AMERICAN PIPELINE ON
THE FIRST DAY AND STOPPING
LEASES.
HE MADE US DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA,
SAUDI ARABIA AND NOW VENEZUELA.
HE HATES AMERICAN OIL FIELD
WORKERS SO MUCH HE WILL NEVER
TURN TO US?
I MEAN THINK FOR A MOMENT.
AMERICA COULD BE EMERGENCY
INDEPENDENT.
THE PRICE OF OUR  -- GAS WOULD
BE LAYER AND AMERICA WOULD BE
STRONGER AND NO DEPENDENT.
WE'RE SO ABUNDANT WHEN IT COMES
TO ENERGY WE COULD HAVE OTHER
NATIONS DEPENDENT ON US SO THE
WORLD WOULD BE SAFER.
SO RUSSIA WOULDN'T BE AS STRONG.
HE ALSO LOWERED THE STANDING OF
AMERICA AROUND THE WORLD.
THE DISRESPECT THAT PEOPLE HAVE
FOR US NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OUR ALLIES
WILL THINK OF US IF WE GO TO
VENEZUELA KNOWING THE REGIME OF
WHAT THEY DO?
THE HORRENDOUS ACTIVITIES THEY
DO?
WHO WOULD RESPECT US ANY MORE?
THEN TO TAKE A RESERVE THAT
AMERICA HAS PUT AWAY TO HELP US
IN A TIME OF NEED, TO EVEN
THREATEN THAT AND WEAKEN US TO
OUR LOWEST LEVEL SINCE 1984 MAKE
US MORE DEPENDENT ON OTHER
NATIONS.
WHY WOULD HE NOT TURN AND LOOK
TO AMERICA?
YOU KNOW IN 33 DAYS IF
REPUBLICANS ARE ABLE TO WIN THE
MAJORITY IN THE COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA, MAKING AN ECONOMY THAT
IS STRONG ONE OF OUR FIRST LINES
OF WORK IS TO MAKE AMERICA
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
THAT MEANS YOU WILL PAY LESS AT
THE PUMP.
HAVE MORE MONEY IN YOUR POCKET.
AND INFLATION WILL COME DOWN.
>> Harris: IT'S ALMOST MINORITY
LEADER IS THOUGH THEY WANT
AMERICANS NOT TO HAVE THINGS
SHIPPED TO US BECAUSE YOU NEED
DIESEL FOR THE BIG TRUCKS.
THEY DON'T WANT US TO DRIVE OUR
OWN CARS BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE
CAN'T AFFORD A $60,000 ELECTRIC
VEHICLE RIGHT NOW.
I GUESS THEY DON'T WANT US TO
HEAT OUR HOMES.
IT IS GETTING CHILLY.
WE ARE HEADED TO WINTER.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE HAS A
TABLE HE WILL CONSIDER FULL OF
OPTIONS.
WHAT CAN CONGRESS DO RIGHT NOW?
I KNOW THE COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
PEOPLE ARE BECOMING FAMILIAR
WITH THAT AS YOU AND HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVES CANVAS THE
COUNTRY TELLING PEOPLE ABOUT
WHAT COULD BE COMING NEXT WITH A
RED WAVE POTENTIALLY.
THERE ARE 33 DAYS LEFT AND A LOT
OF CONCERN OUT THERE AND IT IS
CHILLY IN A LOT OF PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY AND PEOPLE HAVE TO DRIVE
TO WORK.
YOUR STATE HAS SOME OF THE
HIGHEST GAS IN THE COUNTRY THAT
WE'VE SEEN SINCE BEFORE THE
SUMMER.
>> YOU KNOW WHY?
THE SAME DEMOCRATIC POLICIES.
THAT GAVIN U NEWSOM SHUT DOWN
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID?
WE DIDN'T STOP USING IT.
HE TURNED TO PUTIN AND STARTED
BUYING 50,000 BARRELS AND
CHANGED OUR GRID WHERE IT'S
WEAKER.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE HAS DONE NOW?
INCREASED OUR ELECTRICITY BILLS
BY 50%.
WHEN IT BECOMES WARM HE TELLS US
WE CAN'T USE ELECTRICITY BECAUSE
WE'LL HAVE A BROWN OUT.
HE DICTATES WHAT TYPE OF CAR WE
CAN BUY.
IT HAS TO BE ELECTRIC.
TELLS US WE CAN'T CHARGE IT.
AMERICA SHOULD WAKE UP.
THEY KNEW THEIR POLICIES WOULD
BRING US THIS DIRECTION.
REMEMBER WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
WAS ASKED ABOUT $FIVE GAS A FEW
MONTHS BACK AND SMILED AND SAID
IT WAS A GOOD THING.
YOU WOULD FORCE PEOPLE TO GO
ELECTRIC.
BUT HE ALSO HAS PUT AMERICA IN A
WEAKER POSITION.
HE THREATENED OUR SECURITY BY
MAKING US DEPENDENT ON OTHER
NATIONS.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, AMERICAN NATURAL
GAS IS 41% CLEANER THAN RUSSIAN
NATURAL GAS.
WE CAN BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS NATION CAN
BE STRONGER WITH MORE JOBS.
OTHER NATIONS DEPENDENT ON US.
CHINA COULD BE DEPENDENT ON US
AND IT WOULD HELP FOREIGN POLICY
AND ALSO MAKE A WORLD A SAFER
PLACE.
>> Harris: THE KIND OF LEVERAGE
WE WOULD HAVE THEN.
IS THERE AN EMERGENCY VALVE
CONGRESS CAN PUT IN PLACE TO
KEEP BIDEN FROM TAPPING THE
RESERVES THAT WE CAN'T REPLENISH
RIGHT NOW?
>> 33 DAYS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
JOIN WITH US, GO TO TAKE THE
HOUSE.COM.
PUT A CHECK AND BALANCE ON THIS.
DON'T LET AMERICA FALL DOWN.
WE CAN MAKE THE NEXT CENTURY
LARGE.
THE ONLY PARTY WITH A PLAN FOR A
NEW DIRECTION.
THE COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
>> Harris: LET'S STAY WITH THE
POLITICS NOW.
THIS TIME THE TOPIC IS CRIME.
VOTERS ARE TELLING US IT IS TOP
OF MIND FOR THEM.
A NEW HEADLINE FROM "POLITICO"
SAYS MID-TERM ELECTION VOTERS
ARE SAYING CRIME AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ARE A POTENT MIX WHEN IT
COMES TO THE VOTE.
BECAUSE OF THAT, MORE AND MORE
ADS ARE HITTING LEFT WING
CANDIDATES FOR THEIR LAX ON
CRIME STANCE.
LET'S WATCH TOGETHER.
>> THE FAR LEFT JOHN FETTERMAN
IS TOO FAR LEFT.
HE IS DANGEROUSLY LIBERAL ON
CRIME.
>> HE IS TALKING ABOUT DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
NOW MURDER IS UP IN MILWAUKEE
40%.
THE FOURTH HIGHEST INCREASE IN
THE COUNTRY.
MANDELA BARNES, A DANGEROUS
DEMOCRAT.
>> Harris: RECENT FOX NEWS POLLS
SHOW A HUGE MAJORITY ARE
EXTREMELY OR VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT HIGHER CRIME RATES ACROSS
AMERICA.
79%, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHY IS
CRIME RISING?
WHY IS CRIME AT A LEVEL IT
HASN'T BEEN IN 20 YEARS?
DEMOCRATS DEFUNDED THE POLICE
AND APPOINTED WOKE D.A.S.
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL SAFE IN THEIR
STREETS.
WE HAVE DRUGS, FENTANYL KILLING
A YOUNGER GENERATION.
THEY OPENED UP THE BORDER.
SOMEBODY GETS ARRESTED BUT LET
OUT BEFORE THE OFFICER IS OFF
DUTY.
I DID A ROUND TABLE YESTERDAY ON
FENTANYL IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
WITH D.E.A.
HOMELAND SECURITY, F.B.I. AND
SHERIFF AND POLICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM WAS?
NOT THAT THE BORDER WAS JUST
OPEN AND COMING FROM CHINA TO
MEXICO.
THEY CAN'T FIND PEOPLE TO WORK
FOR THEM.
DO THEY NEED MORE FUNDING?
THEY SAID NO THE DEFUNDING OF
THE POLICE AND EVERY ELEMENT
THEY AREN'T GETTING PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO APPLY TO THE JOB
ANY MORE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEMOCRAT POLICY THAT THEY
PROMOTED, THAT THEY MOVED
THROUGH IN A COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA WE BUILD ON A NATION
THAT IS SAFE.
WE SECURE OUR BORDER, WE DON'T
DEFUND THE OFFICERS, WE ADD
200,000 POLICE OFFICERS.
AND THEN WE SCORE EVERY SINGLE
PROSECUTOR IN AMERICA SO PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND ARE THEY UPHOLDING
THE LAW OR NOT?
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT
YOU WILL GET ON JANUARY 3RD IN A
NEW PLAN WITH A NEW DIRECTION.
>> Harris: MINORITY LEADER
MCCARTHY, I WOULD ONLY ADD THIS
TO THE MIX YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT.
THAT IS YOU WANT THE QUALIFIED
-- YOU HAVE TO INCENTIVIZE THE
BEST AMONG TO COME FORWARD.
ADMIT YOU WERE WRONG WHEN YOU
GOT RID OF THEM AND TOOK THEIR
PAY AWAY.
IT HAS TO BE PART OF THE PLAN.
WITHOUT THAT HEALING I DON'T
KNOW IF WE GO FOR IT
AUTOMATICALLY.
YOUR LAST THOUGHT.
>> IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
THERE IS HOPE.
IN SAN FRANCISCO IT HAS LESS
THAN 7% REPUBLICAN REGISTRATION.
THEY RECALLED THEIR SCHOOL BOARD
AND RECALLED THEIR D.A. IN THE
LAST YEAR.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS IS ABOUT AMERICANS FEELING
SAFE.
THEY KNOW THE POLICIES THAT HAVE
BEEN PROMOTED BY ONE DEMOCRAT
RULE IN WASHINGTON.
THEY CONTROL EVERYTHING.
PUT US IN A PLACE WE NO LONGER
FEEL SAFE.
IN 33 DAYS IT CAN ALL CHANGE.
JOIN WITH US.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE GLAD YOU WERE IN "FOCUS"
TODAY RIGHT AFTER THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WE WERE
ABLE